Hi to you and welcome to this intelligence squared podcast,
which is being hosted by me, uh, Sonya soda,
I'm chief leader writer at the observer and an observer and guardian columnists.
And I'm really excited to be hosting this conversation today with Laura Bates,
who is funneled through the everyday sexism project.
She's the author of many books on feminism, including the burning,
her latest book. It just, just out is called men who hate women.
I've got a copy of it here. Um, I've read it. I've written about it.
I would highly recommend it to all of you. If you enjoy this conversation.
I think it's a very important book and the more people that read it the better.
So do go and get a copy. Um,
a quick mindset before we kick off the conversation with Laura.
If you do enjoy today's podcast,
we'd really appreciate you pressing the like button and subscribing to the
channel. And if you've got thoughts on our discussion,
do you feel free to leave a comment in the comments section for that?
So without further ado, we will kick off with Nora. Um, Laura,
I guess, first of all, it'd be just great to hear the backstory to this,
but how did you come to write a book about men who hate women?
Well, I've been aware of these communities for some time. Um,
and I think I started thinking about this around the time that we saw the
resurgence of the me too movement.
And it felt like we were in a very positive place in many ways.
And that thanks to the courage and the bravery of millions of survivors,
we were finally becoming more comfortable as a society,
having a conversation about sexual violence, about sexual harassment,
and yet still we were comfortable talking about women as victims,
but very uncomfortable,
even then with the idea of a conversation about groups of men as perpetrators.
And I started to think about the existence of these communities,
which are actively inciting and carrying out hate,
fueled violent attacks on women and how we could tackle something like that.
If people didn't even know it existed for me, the tipping point was, um,
recognizing the extent to which these communities were grooming and radicalizing
school boys.
So in my work in schools where I regularly speak in perhaps two schools a week
suddenly started hearing perhaps two years ago,
increasing numbers of boys regurgitating false facts
and identical quotes in schools from rural Scotland to inner city London,
where it was very clear that they had been groomed online by the same groups and
the same people.
So they were saying things like they believed that the vast majority of rape
allegations are false men everywhere were losing their jobs because of a
wave of totally fake stories made up by women to undermine them, um,
that the gender pay gap is a feminist myth that there's a feminist conspiracy at
the heart of our government, um,
set on undermining and attacking white men who are the real victims of the vast
majority of inequality in today's society.
And there was a real intolerance of any opposing views or,
or different facts or figures,
even though I knew that the figures in the statistics that they gained from
these online movements were false and quite startlingly. So, you know,
things like 90% of rape allegations are false, that kind of thing.
And how would you respond when you got boys sort of,
and young men standing up in sort of, you know,
assembly halls or classrooms putting these things to you?
Well, as gently as possible, because I think the problem with radicalization,
which is what this is, and if it were any other group doing it,
we would be using that terminology is that they've already been very cleverly
primed to, um,
understand that you have been brainwashed and anybody that tries to talk them
out a bit is a kind of feminine artsy, left-wing PC warrior,
snowflake, whatever. So going in hard with this is nonsense. It doesn't help.
You have to listen. You have to be prepared to, um,
listen to their fears and their anxieties. Um, for me,
I found that one of the most useful things was to talk in detail about the
impact of gender inequality, gender stereotyping, um,
masculinity, and a kind of societal version of how that should play out on boys,
themselves to talk about male crises, the male mental health crisis,
to talk about body image impacting on young men to really make it clear that
this isn't about one group against another,
but that actually all the issues that feminists are fighting have a massive
positive knock-on impact and also about lifting up and supporting boys and men
and their experiences as well.
I want to come back to this issue of kind of radicalization, um, very soon,
um, what you saw happening in schools and why you think that is.
But first of all, I'd like to just get you to sort of,
you sort of look at a number of different online socialistic
movements. And I wonder if first of all,
you could just give our listeners a bit of a summary in a nutshell,
what those movements in that tap work.
Absolutely. So this is a group of communities and movements loosely, um,
under the umbrella term of the manosphere. It's not my term.
I don't think it's a particularly useful term because it's not.
Minimized. Yeah, it's.
A little sad. It makes it sound like a joke. And like it's kind of pathetic,
which is how many people react to these movements when they hear about them
mistakenly in my view. Um,
but the individual communities within the magnetosphere,
which I looked at include at the most extreme and in cells also called
involuntary celibates. These are men who are not having sex and want it to be.
And instead of looking at their own hatred of women as being part of the
potential reason for that, um,
they focus on the idea that evil inhuman women are denying,
what is their birthright as men.
And they fantasize about raping women about keeping them as sex slaves and about
a day of retribution. And in cell rebellion,
when these men will rise up and slaughter, the stuck-up spoiled,
beautiful women who have refused to sleep with them and the men who are managing
to have sex with those women in some cases.
So these sound like very extreme and probably very small group of people.
But the reality I discovered was actually a really sprawling community and
hundreds of thousands across blogs websites, um, online chat rooms,
support groups, forums message boards.
And these are men who have gone offline and acted on this ideology.
These are men who have committed massacres offline of women in the name of this
ideology, but it hasn't been called terrorism, whether by the police,
the justice system or the media,
and what sort of massacres are we talking about?
So we're talking about the Santa Barbara massacre where Elliot Rodger,
for example, killed six people and injured another 14 or the Toronto van attack,
which many people may have heard of where Alec Manassian deliberately drove a
speeding rental van into pedestrians, um,
killing 10 people in during another 16, most of them women, um,
but more cases as well,
a teenage boy named Ben Moynihan in the UK who attempted to murder three
separate women over a two month period by stabbing them a case in Canada earlier
this year where a teenage boy took a machete into a massage parlor and murdered
a woman. Um, another man in Canada this year who attempted to, um,
murder a woman and her toddler girl had female baby, um,
in the parking lot of a, of a shop. Um,
these are not the only cases in the book.
I've traced this ideology directly to over a hundred deaths or serious injuries
in the last 10 years.
And these are men who have explicitly carried out these acts in the name of a
hate fueled vitriolic ideology of a misogynistic extremism.
So it meets every definition,
every level of what's required to define it as terrorism internationally.
And yet that isn't a definition that's brought to bear on almost any of the
cases with one exception,
the boy with the machete who has been charged with a terror offense.
Um, so we will come back again to this idea of terrorism and why you seem so
reluctant as a society to put these sorts of attacks into the category of
terrorism. But just before we do that,
tell me about the other online communities you laptop.
So then there are men going their own way.
These are men who believe that women are so dangerous and toxic with their false
rape allegations with their tendency to, um,
cheat on their husbands and secretly have babies,
and then force men to bring up those children that aren't actually their own,
um, with their false workplace, sexual harassment allegations that strict men,
if they're jobs that they believe the safest possible course of action is simply
to cut out of your life altogether, to have nothing to do with them,
no sexual or romantic relationships, if possible, no contact at all.
Again, sounds very extreme and ridiculous,
and it's easy to dismiss as a kind of a internet cul-de-sac with a few
men. But the reality is that this is becoming an incredibly popular ideology.
There was a recent study, for example,
found that 27% of American men now refuse to have one-on-one meetings with
female colleagues in the workplace.
And of course the vice president of the United States,
Mike Pence famously refuses to have dinner alone with any woman other than his
wife. So this is another good example, I think,
of a community easily dismissed, but in reality, you know,
some of the bigger leaders of this community, which is very active on YouTube,
um, they have views and followers and views of their videos in,
in the tens or even hundreds of millions.
So we are talking about something more pervasive than you might think.
And then there are pickup artists. Um, again,
this is a kind of related community because like in sales,
they view women very much as sex objects there, um,
for the sole purpose of providing sex to men. Um,
but if you think of in and pickup artists by saying women as kind of sexual slot
machines,
and so think that the machines are rigged and we'll never pay out to them,
pick up artists,
believe that anybody anywhere can be taught the secret combination of buttons to
press and leavers to pull to force any woman to have sex with them almost
against her. Well, they talk about women in terms of training Labradors,
essentially. Um, they talk about using, um,
verbal ticks to kind of trick and only hitting the ties women.
They talk about deliberately sexually harassing women in the street or in public
space when women don't want to talk to them.
And at the more extreme end they talk about overcoming last minute resistance,
which means forcing a woman to have sex with you when she changed her mind
essentially. Right? Absolutely.
And these are men who have sometimes boasted about rape in their kind of guru
classes that they're providing to other men they're gurus and leading lights of
this industry who had training of the men in these so-called techniques have
uploaded videos of themselves online, sexually assaulting,
strange women in the street. Um, they've made arguments for example,
that rape should be illegalized on public property.
So it's much darker and much bigger phenomenon than our kind of pop
culture representation of sort of Bonnie Stinson and how I met your mother or
Joey and friends might suggest.
I mean, so we, as feminists are supposed to kind of be feeling positive,
especially in the wake of kind of me too, as you mentioned, you know,
attitudes are supposed to be changing,
particularly amongst the generation younger generation of girls and boys growing
up to be young men and women. Um,
but this really sounds horribly kind of dark ages. So I guess,
what is it that's attracting men to these communities?
How are they building themselves?
Well, it's complicated. Um,
I think early sort of superficial analyses of these communities tend to suggest
that perhaps there is a big class element that it's as a,
kind of about poor white boys being left behind.
But if you look at the demographics of these communities while that is evidence
to suggest that they're predominantly white, um,
there are also large numbers of men within them who seem to be, um, uh,
middle-class um, fairly independently wealthy, um,
white men college educated who sort of believe that that sense of
entitlement to certain positions in society is being challenged and threatened,
um, by progress towards equality.
So certainly you could say that one aspect of this is a backlash to a burgeoning
feminist movement.
There is certainly evidence to suggest that this movement has exploded as the
current wave of feminism has gained in kind of, um, public awareness.
Um, I'd say, for example, if you look at four Chan,
which is one of the communities where we knew that, um,
often people start their journeys into the manosphere where you'll see trolls
gathering. For example,
that's a website that gets 28 million unique monthly video, uh, visitors,
and by far its most popular, um, board sort of area on the website is,
um, the random one,
which is the one my trolls tend to congregate that demographic is overwhelmingly
white college educated men between the ages of about 18 and 34.
So that kind of backs up that theory.
I would say the college-educated thing it's really surprising to me because you
would expect maybe you've been to university to be a bit more liberal.
Yeah. I mean,
I think we have to be careful with the idea that younger men are kind of coming
up with different attitudes and that things are sort of generally getting better
if we just sit back and wait every year,
the British attitude survey asks people whether they think a woman was fully or
partly to blame for being raped if she had been flirting or if she was drunk and
every year very depressing.
The answer comes back that a culture of the British public thinks she was to
blame if she'd been drinking. And the third, if she'd been flirting,
but every year amongst younger people, amongst 18 year olds,
that figure is much higher.
So there is evidence to suggest that young people's attitudes might actually be
more extreme when it comes to misogyny and victim blaming than we might like to
think. But it's also the case.
I think that a lot of the people drawn into these communities have very real
problems and vulnerabilities because we're talking about communities in the
hundreds of thousands. Obviously it's a very complex and nuanced picture.
Obviously not all of these men are going out and killing women offline.
Obviously not all of them were even talking about that or inciting that.
And there's certainly evidence that some of the people in these communities are
men who have had very difficult, personal experiences,
offline men who are affected by social isolation,
by mental health problems and vulnerable teenagers who are anxious.
You have understandable questions and anxieties about ghosts,
and I've been kind of sucked into this vortex by their very deliberate kind of
recruitment strategies.
So one problem I think is that we're not tackling these kinds of issues offline.
We've seen 600 youth centers closed in the last few years.
We've seen huge slashes to funding for youth workers and all of this affects
young people.
And in particular young men's mental health and makes them ripe targets for
this kind of online radicalization.
Yes, you, that, there's that word again, radicalization.
So I wonder if you could just talk me through what you mean by that word and
what it looks like for kids. You know, these are boys who probably sort of,
you know, Googling in cell movement, uh, when they're looking for stuff.
So explain to me how they come across this and in you actually post didn't you
as a sort of young man as part of your research.
So I'd just be interested in hearing more about that and the role that
technology plays in it.
Yeah, of course. So I saw firsthand how this happens.
These communities are extremely tech savvy.
They're extremely adept at using the internet and using the kind of terminology
of the internet to very slowly and carefully groomed boys.
So absolutely boys that have been affected by this kind of ideology might never
have actually heard the term in cell by and large.
The boys I come into contact with in schools,
aren't necessarily members of individual in sale or pickup artistry communities.
They're coming into contact with the material in the ideology of these
communities,
but sort of smuggled further downstream and very easily accessible. Um,
uh, mint means, for example,
Instagram comedy means cultural touch points and references
viral videos. And this isn't a coincidence,
so that it's been deliberately written by members of these extremist communities
that they see these viral comedy names and jokes and images and
videos and direct links to popular culture as a way of what they describe as
adding cherry flavor to children's medicine in order to target boys as young as
11 and with a very gradual drip, drip,
drip of desensitization to mysogeny then slowly dragging them down
further towards jokes,
about rape until eventually get to the point where the joke isn't necessarily a
joke anymore.
And they very much see it as well as a slipway to other forms of radicalization.
That's really important to note,
I think this is very much tied up with the alt-right with white
supremacy and may not see as him and neo-Nazis are deliberately seeing
extreme mysogeny and anti-feminist rhetoric as a kind of way to
open the door to those other forms of white supremacist ideologies.
And they're able to do it because social media platforms have the most enormous
influence. YouTube, for example, has 1.5 billion users,
which is bigger than the number of households that own a TV and their impact on
young people's particularly extreme. I think for adults,
we think YouTube as the home of movie trailers and from B cat videos.
So it's easy to kind of dismiss it in terms of the influence it has as a
platform,
but we know it's the most popular social media platform amongst young people.
We know that the majority of young people say that YouTube is where they get
their news from. And if you look at the numbers,
it's absolutely mind-boggling.
So we know that 37% of all global internet traffic
is accounted for by YouTube alone.
And we know that 70% of the videos people watch on YouTube are the ones
recommended to them by the algorithm,
after they finished watching what they went looking for.
It's important because the algorithm directs people towards videos that will
serve YouTube.
Basically all YouTube wants is to keep you watching for as long as it can.
So whistleblowers who have left the engineering team of YouTube have come out
and said, listen, this algorithm isn't directing you to the best content,
the highest quality or the most relevant it's is absolutely focusing on
directing you towards increasingly extreme content,
because that's what keeps people watching.
So if you're watching a video about picnics and suddenly you're watching an all,
you can eat challenge, that's not such a big deal.
If you're watching a video about jogging and it takes you to extreme marathon
runners, that's not such a big deal,
but if you started out asking something quite insipid, like what is feminism?
And suddenly within a couple of videos,
you're being told that evil women are ruining the world and whiteness.
That literally what happens in the us sort of question into YouTube.
Yes. So in the book specifically,
I kind of take you through this as I did it myself and I started with the
question, what is feminism?
And it came up with a really innocuous video of Emma Watson speaking at the UN,
but the next 10 videos that came up that were recommended by the algorithm
started off with talking about how the gender pay gap is a myth and how the
modern feminist movement is very bitter and angry and lesbian.
That was Milo Yiannopoulos being interviewed saying that that was his word,
not mine. Um,
and then gradually on to more and more kind of conspiracy theories until you
reach a point of being told that women hate men,
that feminists are taking over the world, that white men are under attack,
that rape allegations are false within literally just a few videos without even
having to click anything. So it matters then at that point,
if you put those two stats together from earlier and you realize 25% of all
mobile internet traffic globally is just accounted for by people
watching the videos, YouTube has chosen for them to watch. At that point,
it really matters that the YouTube algorithm has essentially been hijacked
by a vast influence,
a network of extreme misogynistic and alt-right figures.
And that is very much taking young people down a kind of algorithmic rabbit
hole.
So you sort of set out in your book, how, you know,
extreme misogynistic ideology has actually led to real world
massacres, um, women and men losing their lives. Um,
when you talk about radicalization, it,
it feels to me like they were real and grooming.
It feels to me that there are real parallels there with how we see young people
kind of indoctrinated into far right. Or Islamist ideology, for example.
So I guess my, you know, and,
and then you've talked as well about the links between online extreme
misogyny and far right ideology.
So why do you think we're struggling as a society to see this as
terrorism and to take counter-terrorist approaches to it?
I think there are two reasons.
I think the first is that people have very little idea of the existence of these
communities, a tool, or if they do know about them,
of the extent of them, of how vitriolic and hate field they are,
if the extent to which they are inciting and acting on incitement to offline
violence, um, and of the sheer numbers of people involved.
So the first thing is people don't know these communities even exist,
which makes it very difficult to protect boys from being radicalized by them.
But the second problem I think, is that even where we do talk about it,
even where men who have committed massacres have outright said in their police
interviews, that they were radicalized online, that they hated women,
that they were murdering these women for not having sex with them.
Police chiefs will still come out and give an interview to the international
media saying there is no evidence that this is linked to terrorism.
What that means,
I think is that we have a very specific idea as a society of what we consider to
be terrorism.
And we see this already in the way in which we deal very differently in the
media with terrorists, who are acting in the name of, for example,
extreme Islamist ideology or white supremacy, we tend to see headlines.
Well, first of all,
they're much more likely to be reported on a tool if the perpetrator is Muslim.
Secondly, the headlines tend to emphasize evil terrorists.
In one of those cases, when we talk about kind of the baby face child,
you turned out to be a killer. If it's a white man, we talk about lone wolves.
We talk about outliers.
We talk about isolated incidents and freak accidents and mental health problems.
So already, when we're talking about white men as perpetrators,
we are much less likely to see them as part of an extremist ideology,
but then go even one step further when that extremist ideology is
extremist misogyny, I think it fits into a pattern that we consider normal.
We are so used to seeing women losing their lives to men,
leave it to women every week. It killed by a current or former partner.
One in three women on the planet will be raped or beaten at some point in her
lifetime. So the phenomenon of male,
hatred and violence against women is normal to us.
It is very much part of the wallpaper and that makes it more difficult for
people to recognize this as an extremist hate movement, right?
And it's not just.
Terrorism where we see that minimize this. I'm thinking of, you know,
for years,
women have been pointing out newspaper headlines that minimize domestic abuse
and murder that happens in the home or the so-called private sphere,
uh, where women are, as you say, killed or killed by former or current partners.
Uh, yeah, the story is all on, you know, how a mom was provoked for example.
Yes, exactly. So in the book I highlight recent headlines, for example,
that described men who have massacred their families as one was described as a
henpecked husband and the headline one was described as a BBQ dad,
um, who was desperately sad about the fact that his marriage had broken down.
We tend to excuse and minimize and seek to understand these men.
There was even an article in very recently and one of our biggest read national
newspapers that used the word understandable in describing a man who had
massacred, not only his wife, but also his teenage daughter. Um,
it's,
it's so common to try and look for justification and excuses for these men.
And the real tragedy is that they are directly linked to terrorism.
So there was for example,
a big study by the every town group in the United States of, um,
massacres that had occurred mass killings,
terror attacks between 2009 and 2018 during which period and
54% of the cases, um, an intimate family member, um,
had been killed as part of the massacre and around a third of the perpetrators
of mass attacks in the U S have a history of domestic violence, abuse, stalking,
or peace of women.
So the connections are that if we were to take domestic violence, seriously,
the red flags that they provide could have a massive impact in helping us to
prevent other atrocities. But as always for generations,
women have been canaries singing in coal mines,
dying quietly and going completely unheard.
What is the impact of this on women and indeed men on
society? I mean, obviously there's a very extreme end,
what you talk about the sort of massacres that we've seen by themselves,
but how else has this mode testing itself?
Well, that's what I'm really interested in. Actually,
obviously we can talk about and define the incidents.
We can pinpoint the incidents where men have murdered in the name of these
ideologies.
What we don't know is the sheer extent of the impact these ideologies might be
having as they sort of slid the offline into schools into classrooms,
there is strong into homes.
There's strong evidence that members of a men's rights activist groups,
which is another one of the communities that I look at in the book, um, have,
for example, caught the ear of policy makers in the United States,
in Australia, in the UK, we have currently serving politicians.
One of them on our women in equality committee who have spoken,
who's spoken at men's rights conferences and,
and openly whilst holding important positions in our government relating to
justice.
For example said that the justice system is horribly stacked against men and
boys and advantages women and girls.
So actually the impact of these groups is potentially quite massive
and at a personal level as well.
If we have tens of thousands of men on websites,
learning a woman really wants to be raped. You're just playing into her fantasy,
for example, which is a very normal quote from a pickup website,
how many women in their everyday lives may have come into contact with perhaps
been sexually assaulted by a man whose ideology has been influenced by the
manosphere. There's a horrible case in the book, for example,
of a rape victim who found her rape in chilling
detail on a pickup artist dream website where her rapists had
detailed everything that had happened as a kind of triumphant report to their
peers. Um, so I think the potential impact is,
is much greater than the size of the communities and certainly if
their size might suggest.
And I'm also thinking that, you know,
if you're a boy coming into contact with this stuff,
and you're quite formative years when you're sort of thinking about, you know,
your relationships with girls and young women, um,
you don't have to become an incell for this to impact on how you interact with
women, your first few girlfriends, how you treat them. And I, I, you know,
I can imagine it'd be very difficult to measure,
but I would be worried about some of the stuff that I read in your book,
even if it's quite low level being associated, for example,
with coercive control and domestic abuse.
Absolutely.
And I think that's where it comes down to recognizing that this is a form of
radicalization because if it's able to happen silently,
then there are generation of boys coming into contact with this ideology without
any kind of offsetting information,
without any attempt to give them alternative facts and information.
And the impact of that could be really massive. I mean,
an example that Springs to mind immediately as a young woman who wrote to me,
um,
in one of her first weeks at university to say that she'd had sex with a boy,
a boyfriend for the first time, um, they were both 18.
And she said that halfway through,
he suddenly started trying to choke her completely out of the blue and
unexpectedly. And she managed to push him off.
And afterwards he broke down in tears and said,
I thought that was what you'd be expecting. So there is,
it is very extreme and it very much overlaps, I think,
with the impact of online pornography, the fact that, you know,
we knew that 60% of young people have seen online form by the age of 14 and a
quarter to 12 or younger when they first see it.
So we're talking about ideas which, um,
contribute to the kind of dehumanization of their female peers to the idea that
the way to be a man is to have power and sexual control over,
to be dominant, to be an alpha male, to be strong.
And all of this is kind of fed into,
and these aren't just my own anecdotal observations for the book.
I interviewed the lead facilitator of the good lad initiative,
which is probably the biggest UK organization on the ground talking to young
boys about this regularly.
And he estimated that 70% of the young people he worked with in schools across
the UK had come into contact with these ideologies in some form.
So this isn't a small minor problem.
I think, you know, so I said at the start, this is a really important,
but in some ways it's also quite a scary book. Um, you know,
and I've talked to a lot of friends about it, my friends with children,
because I think if you've got a young boy,
it's quite an added young girl, to be honest,
it's very important to kind of be aware of this,
but I guess what would your message,
what would your message be to parents who are really worried about some
teachers? What can they do?
I think there is a lot they can do, and that's quite reassuring to hear, um,
I also want to say that this isn't an attempt at scaremongering, you know,
although I do think this is impacting boys to a great degree.
I also know that I'm meeting boys across the country who are really interested
in feminism and advancing equality who are really keen to be part of the
solution as well.
So that's important to say there are all sorts of positive signs about teenage
boys today, as well as teachers and parents.
I think the first thing and the most important thing is to familiarize yourself
with the reality of young people's online worlds and the territory that they
frequent on a daily basis,
because that can be a big gap between adult perceptions of what that looks like
and the reality of the wallpaper of young people's online lives.
So I'd recommend getting stuck in, you know,
type in feminism or feminist gets destroyed on YouTube and just see the kind of
string of what the algorithm presents.
You have a look at some of the bigger red pill sites on Reddit, even sign up,
perhaps for some of the big comments.
Red pill just brought our lessons. You may not be familiar with that.
Say red pill is a term used by almost all of these manners,
fear groups to, um, describe the moment of taking the red pill,
which is borrowed from the matrix. Ironically,
a film by two trans women with these communities being very transphobic.
They don't seem to know the irony of that.
The idea is that when you take the red pill,
it's the moment when you see the reality of the world for how it really is the
scales fall away,
and you realize you've been lied to your whole life and that the world,
which you've been told discriminates against women or against people of color is
actually desperately stacked against poor white men who are the real victims of
our society.
So looking at kind of Reddit red pill websites is a good way to get an idea of
the kind of baseline of this kind of stuff.
Then you can look out for particular words that teenagers might use.
That would be a good indication that they've come across this content normies,
which is the word that they use for kind of members of society outside the
manosphere, um, words like based or triggered or butters,
which are what they use to describe people.
Who've been kind of offended by Monas fare rhetoric or ideology. Um,
anybody who's kind of had a Sutton recent change in views and particularly
marked by a real intolerance to alternative use.
That can be a really big red flag for radicalization. And for me,
communication is the single most important way to tackle this young people.
If they don't have anywhere else to talk,
to add these kinds of grievances and anxieties and fears,
then the manifests we'll welcome them with open arms.
So it's not about judging them or making them feel punished or that
they are going to be sort of, um, you know, held in contempt for this.
It's very much about giving them space to communicate.
And I'd really recommend for schools and parents to think about possibly looking
at an initiative like the good lad initiative coming into talk to peoples.
They are fantastic because they send cool men,
young guys into schools to talk to boys and guys that they'll be able to look up
to and relate to hit knew exactly who won't make them feel judged or
punished, or that they're about to get in trouble,
but who will give them space to interrogate some of this stuff and helping them
to question online sources and to realize that they can't necessarily trust
everything that they read online,
helping them to interrogate it for themselves rather than just telling them that
they're wrong is key, I think.
And is there any evidence about what works once sort of a young man has kind of
got quite drawn into this race and the process of radicalization is
well underway. Is there any evidence about what works in on doing that?
So sadly we have to draw the evidence from this, um,
from other forms of 50 radicalization, because as far as I'm aware,
there is nothing dedicated in terms of deescalation or de-radicalization
organizations focusing specifically on these extremist forms of misogyny.
But if you look at some of the de radicalization projects that are targeting
neo-Nazis and white supremacists,
they often focus on demolishing the idea of the other as a kind of
monstrous character chore. So for example, um,
there's one expert who recently gave an interview in the Atlantic where he
talked about, um, introducing a white supremacist, Neo Nazi, um,
to an mm.
And them actually striking up this great friendship and creating
this relationship that helped to dismantle a lot of the myths that have been fed
to this man as he was radicalized, um,
about what it meant to be a Muslim about what kind of person you would be. Now,
whenever I apply this to what we're talking about, people immediately go,
but that couldn't happen with,
with boys and girls because they mix because they grow up together. So,
you know, why are you saying that?
But I really believe we have a problem with gender segregation and our society,
our schools from the age of being a toddler.
If two children sit down next to each other in a play group,
you'll hear people going, Oh no, they're on their first date.
Look up your dark daughters. She's going to be a heartbreaker.
We sexualize and thereby stigmatize,
mixed gender friendships amongst children from an incredibly young age and
actually at a round table meeting recently about education and sexism.
I was sitting next to a young Muslim teacher. He said,
if the children in my classroom was segregated by religion or race,
I would consider it to be a huge problem.
And so with the school and we take action every day at lunchtime,
the six or seven year olds in my classroom separate themselves,
invariably every day by gender.
And it's not seen as a problem is even almost encouraged.
It seems as normal different views, its natural voice.
It interested in these feelings.
Girls are like this boys and girls are different. They have different interests.
Oh look, the party invitations are pink princess one.
So we won't invite any boys to your party this year.
And it just happens to such a degree that by the time these films are fragile,
highlight stations start to chip in.
They are able to avert and de-humanize female peers because boys don't
necessarily have meaningful platonic relationships with them.
So although it seems very far away from the problem at a kind of broader level,
trying to dismantle some of these gender stereotypes and the way in which we
treat relationships platonically between boys and girls could have a big impact
as well, I think.
And what are the social media companies doing?
I feel like I know the answer to this already, but are they doing enough?
I really don't think they're doing enough.
And I really think they could do more.
I just think we have to look at the relationship between the amount of power
they have and the amount of accountability. And for me,
that is a very unskewed balance at the moment. You know,
if you're talking about your choice of what your algorithm chooses
representing us quarter of mobile internet traffic,
that is enormous power that you're wielding.
And frankly, if you have an income, the size of several small countries,
you do have the money to fix this problem. If you wanted to,
what I suspect is that the will isn't there unless it affects their bottom line.
And because we're talking about such vast communities,
the risk for them is that tackling it could alienate a number of their members,
you know, so we hear them kind of holding up their hands and saying, Oh,
it's really difficult to tackle this with algorithms. We're doing our best,
but it's a real problem,
but I'm sorry you have multi-billion dollars worth of profits. So you could,
if you wanted to hire a hundred thousand human moderators tomorrow and train
them alongside civil society organizations to deal with this manually, um,
I think that they value the, um, perception of their sites.
I, some of them are extreme users above the safety,
on their platforms of women and girls and other grades.
And just to round up, um,
well what are the reasons that you see to sort of be optimistic going forward?
Well,
I think that there is enormous room for improvement here and I'm hoping that
this starts a conversation because we can't fix it unless we can start to talk
about it. Um,
I feel that young people are really giving me a great deal of hope for the
future. You know, the schools that I go into,
these are a generation of young people who have been labeled cowards and
snowflakes and, and you know, PC warriors.
It really couldn't be further from the truth.
This is a generation of young people who are brave or courageous who are
standing up for themselves and fighting back in very difficult circumstances.
Um, you know,
there are girls being told to go home from school because their leggings might
distract the boys who are coming up to school.
The next day with placards protesting saying are my liking flare and you'll test
schools. Um,
these are schools where girls who've been told that they can't hold a feminist
society because it might be considered controversial or divisive or going
underground and holding one anyway, you know,
there is so much going on there so many inspiring and people, um,
who are aware of their stuff and are fighting back against it.
And that gives me hope for the future.
Well, I think that's a great note to end on Laura.
Thank you so much for a fascinating discussion today. Uh I'm Sonia
[inaudible] and you've been listening to intelligence squared.